euh vous posiez la question du du
déboucher je je rappelle que dans le
cadre de la loi aujourd'hui euh on est
censé dans les cantines de Martinique
mais mais comme de de métropole d'avoir
euh 50 % de production donc de qualité
ou 20 % de bio ou siges de qualité et
qu'on sait aujourd'hui que les objectifs
fixés par le gouvernement à son propre à
sa propre administration ne sont pas
remplis voilà je je je je dis ça quand
même c'estàdire que moi je veux bien
prendre un certain nombre de
responsabilités à regarder ce qu'on peut
faire mais il faut aussi que tout le
monde de respecte le cadre d'engagement
donc le ministre de l'Agriculture
lui-même a dit qu'il allait veiller à ce
queon puisse monter en charge je je sais
aussi et peut-être les élus ici le
savent mais il y a aussi un sujet quand
même d'accès que quand vous augmentez le
prix de la cantine dans une école c'est
c'est vite un sujet de de de discussion
or voilà il faut qu'on accepte de
discuter de de de ces sujets moi je
dirais que le prix de la cantine pas
trop mon mon sujet mais comme il se
trouve que je suis él local j'entends
aussi ce que ce que les gens disent il
faut accepter que dans un certain nombre
de cas ça puisse valoir un peu plus cher
pas beaucoup plus cher un peu plus cher
et que on peut aussi avoir des produits
importés à bas cût mais qui ne
remplissent pas ces ces objets